so we started out
spinning same time same direction
forward
and we did some pendulum exercises
splitting our brain so we can do two
different things
tell your left hand to slow down stop
spinning
let it stop and swing and just keep that
right hand spinning
then start swinging the left hand is a
pendulum
so you're doing two different things at
once and then you can explore what's
going on with that pendulum and you can
make it a long arm pendulum swing your
arm all the way up to the horizon each
time
you drag that across you're doing a long
arm
pendulum circle your arm circling but
the pendulum is swinging under
dragging across the top of the line you
can do that either way
and we also played eventually with
swinging the pendulum in a small
pendulum circle kind of like
rolling a boat you can do that either
way
so we want to look for when the pendulum
is swinging forward and falling down
and line that up with our other spin so
that you can go
straight back into spinning and of
course you want to try that with the
other hand
too focused on just swinging a pendulum
with one arm
and i use my other poi or a line on the
ground
to signify the track the plane that my
boy is swinging on
so there's an imaginary wall right on
this line and i'm
tracing an arc with my pendulum on it we
started to play around with
moving across the line switching sides
the key is to wait until your pendulum
is swinging
out away from your body so that you
won't hit your body when it's out there
i can step through
the door opens i step through
and we we just kind of freestyled that
and then we played with something a
little trickier where
we swing it up and let it swing behind
our head staying on that line the whole
time
i didn't step over the line this time i
just turned my body around
so i'm facing the wall and facing away
right now my back my back is to the wall
and i keep turning and drop it down
again
then we sort of shifted gears for a
second
and uh played with
being aware of the center line of our
body
we played with some body exercises
that involve swinging the arms in split
time
opposite directions this is very
important
part of the circle of your arms comes
from your
torso twisting and part of it
comes from your shoulder muscles moving
your arms up and down
there's a horizontal component
oscillating back and forth
and a vertical component and when you
put those together
you get some circles and you want to be
able to check
on the horizon at your center line
on the horizon at the center line over
and over again
to see if you're keeping your circling
clean
that's both a good body exercise that
will help with your flowers
but it also set us up for the right
alignment for some of the other stuff we
did
we also played with spinning split time
same direction in the wall plane
split time with the like a buzz saw or a
weave
the circles are all happening on the
same circle
but when you pull your hands apart so
you have two circles happening
when you stay in split time same
direction you'll notice
the poi as wheels are still rolling in
the same direction
but they keep meeting in the very center
passing each other going in contrary
directions
over and over again and that's that's a
focus
point that's something that you want to
recognize to make sure you're keeping
your rhythm
and you can actually play with moving
that around
all over the place while focusing on
always brushing them past each other we
practice that with our hands
as well
where we're just practicing that motion
quarter turns at a time with our hands
so
central focus point up and down
all the way out other up and down center
focus point
playing with rotating that at the elbows
going back the other way
playing with opening that up so they
pass up and down the body one in front
of the other
long arm circles up and down the body
it's all the same sort of timing and
motion they're all they're all going
split time same direction
and that built us up to the ability to
not only
do this sort of thing but to
stack our nice split time same direction
one on top of the other on the center
line
from there
you want to keep your low hand rotating
and with the top hand let it slow
down like we did earlier and start
swinging a pendulum
this is a really good way to actually
start working on the rhythm of your
pendulum
notice how there's two meeting points
there's a moment where
my pendulum and the bottom poi
are both almost like they're
magnetically attracted both swinging
through the middle and
going over in that direction then when
the poi swings back
just like our split time same direction
spinning there's a moment where
the poi rush past each other going in
opposite directions
you can hit that timing that moment of
of like connection in the middle each
time
same opposite same opposite
same opposite
you